you um obviously you're in great shape
right now you're right yeah i'm fair for
a square yeah man um
what dietary things are you doing that
kind of have gotten obviously you're
hitting the gym but in terms of just
like that out of all three times a day
in the gym i got skinny got all that
alcohol which kind of helped me block
all of myself yeah
i was going to say we could get to the
adderall which by the way if you ever
edit video all the video editors i know
are on adorama god bless them
i try this is my first time speaking
about i
i tried out a wrong
i don't say i tried it i did it
as a pre-workout
i did adderall and pre-workout at the
same time yeah i was in the gym like
i was on a mission in my mind
it don't stay focused
well then it didn't stay focused
and then
thank god uh for ambrosia
they came out with this mushroom
pre-workout yeah a lot of people are
doing good yeah
yeah i know people who will microdose
before their workout no i'm i'm i'm on
um ambrosia okay pre-workout
right now that's interesting big handful
of mushrooms i'll take some and recharge
so the adderall though kind of got you
like super focused to get in the gym
initially when you tried it
yeah
yeah i guess
that's what you want to say yeah i it's
a very uh
they say it's like uh what's that that
limitless pill and that move that that
movie where you take it and you you
could get [ __ ] done it's not like that
but
i lost a lot of weight
like when people tell me when people
used to say you had surgery i used to
look at it offensively but like you know
i looked that good that you think i had
surgery but no
they thought you had like a male bbl or
something i think that's wild i think
that's what i don't i about to say i
don't know because i never had that
surgery of course i had been shot before
and i had surgery on my leg
and that was just horrific
and i was like i never willingly undergo
that type of screw yeah you'll never go
under the knife unless you have to yeah
i'm not doing it forgive me i get mine
out the mud which my fitness journey
took a little longer but the beautiful
thing about it was
when i first started working out i was
still doing drugs
then i noticed that
i started slacking up on the drugs
because it was like
you know i don't have any energy to get
up and work out in the morning then i
noticed my work i started being able to
work out more proficient
if that's the right word yeah i mean
efficient proficient efficiently we get
it efficiently yeah yeah so
i noticed that and then i also noticed
that
once i started making small diet changes
it's like i wanted to take my singing
series when i was on tour
and i was reading about all of the
things that caused mucus build up and
i was reading about animal products
so i'm vegan vegan vegan vegan when i'm
on tour when i'm not on tour i'm vegan
but i still eat animal products like
cheese or eggs i love cheese that's well
i love cheese um i love steak vegan
cheese is terrible
i don't want to say that because they
got some vegan cheese that's good i
haven't had i haven't had any of it yeah
they got some vegan cheese that's kind
of good but you're right the mucus of
dairy causes so much mucus it's like
crazy like and i couldn't and it affects
my singing
and
then i started reading about
like
animal products
and
when you're not getting enough
chlorophyll in your body because
chlorophyll is what helps metabolize
animal products
but when you're not getting enough
chloride you feel like damn that's why
they always feed you vegetables
with the steak yeah it helps you digest
it
so and you can have steak once every two
weeks
all things within moderation so i had to
get off of the i'm extra vegan to have
imbalance
yeah i think that there is also like
health benefits to having animal protein
that you probably won't be able to i
like the way i feel when i'm vegan i do
steak every two weeks is a nice